nowadays whatsapp has become a meme on
youtube due to all the bitcoin and
crypto scammers in the comments section
that tell you to contact them through
whatsapp
given this poor association and the
relative unpopularity of whatsapp within
the us a lot of americans likely write
off the app as just a gateway for
scammers but outside the u.s whatsapp is
a lot more than just that
in fact in many developing countries and
europe whatsapp is often the primary
form of communication
instead of using traditional sms and
cellular infrastructure whatsapp uses
the internet to facilitate these
communications which is extremely
convenient and cheap especially for
international communication in other
words whatsapp is basically the imessage
and facetime of non-americans
considering this i don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that whatsapp is the
world's most popular messaging app with
a total of 2 billion active monthly
users despite whatsapp's explosive
success both of whatsapp's founders left
the company in 2018 citing privacy and
monetization concerns so here's what
happened to the founders of the most
popular messaging app in the world
taking a look back the story of whatsapp
circles back to two men named jan kuma
and brian acton jen was born on february
24th 1976 in kiev ukraine to a jewish
family
jan was an only child so his parents
gave him extra love and attention but no
amount of care was able to cover up the
reality of their living situation
jan's house didn't even have running
water and it wasn't much better at
school
jen says that his school didn't even
have a bathroom inside the building
so kids had to run across the parking
lot to just use the bathroom which was
especially painful when the temperature
was negative 20 degrees celsius aside
from poor living conditions jen says
that the social life wasn't that much
better due to all the discrimination
against jews
jan's family had to put up with this for
decades but when jen turned 16 they
decided to immigrate to mountain view
california
this move eliminated a lot of the
outright discrimination they experienced
and the lack of opportunities that
accompany socialism but life in the u.s
was still quite difficult because they
had no money and had trouble
communicating to make ends meet jen's
mother had to start babysitting and jen
had to become a cleaner at a grocery
store the family also had to use welfare
checks and food stamps in terms of
school jen admits that he wasn't the
best of students and that he barely got
through high school but this didn't mean
that he hated learning he enjoyed
reading books about computer science and
teaching himself coding
apparently he would buy coding books
from a local bookstore read them really
fast and then return them to save money
anyway moving on to college jan would
attend san jose state university and he
would pick up a side job as a security
tester at ernst young to pay for his
education
but this job would end up being a lot
more valuable than just helping pay for
college
you see it jan would meet an early yahoo
employee named brian acton while
completing a project for ernst young
six months later brian would help jan
get a job at yahoo and that marked the
beginning of the partnership that would
eventually turn into whatsapp
taking a look back at brian's past it's
a lot different than jan's past brian
was born on february 17th 1972 in
michigan
his mother ran a freight shipping
business and she was the one that really
inspired brian to pursue
entrepreneurship ironically jan actually
hates this word and doesn't like it when
people call him an entrepreneur
he feels that the main goal of
traditional entrepreneurs is to make
money while his main goal is to make
useful products
anyway going back to brian it looks like
he was a star student at school he would
attend a lake howell high school in
central florida and would earn a full
scholarship to study engineering at the
university of pennsylvania he only stuck
around at upenn for a year though before
he switched over to stanford to get a
computer science degree with such a rich
educational background it was easy for
brian to enter the workforce and switch
from one job to another until he found
his calling in 1992 he started off as a
systems administrator at rockwell
international after that he became a
product tester at apple before becoming
a protester at adobe while brian didn't
know exactly what he wanted to do in the
early days he soon found himself looking
back at his childhood and his mother and
decided that he wanted to give
entrepreneurship ashant so in 1996 he
joined yahoo as their 44th employee and
this is where he would meet jankum for
the next decade ryan and jen would stick
around at yahoo and just consistently
save up and invest their money while
their professional lives were
progressing pretty smoothly the same
could not be said about their personal
lives in february of 1996 jan would
verbally and physically threaten an
ex-girlfriend after they broke up and
their girlfriend would end up filing a
restraining order against jen
jan has since expressed that he's
extremely embarrassed and ashamed of his
behavior
in the meantime brian was having a great
time in the late 1990s he was investing
heavily in dot-com companies which made
him a multi-millionaire but once the
dakota bubble burst he would lose most
of it
while i'm sure he was fine financially
thanks to his job and savings this was
likely an extremely painful event
nonetheless the duo got through these
events and would eventually leave yahoo
in 2007. soon after they both tried to
get jobs at facebook but both of them
would be rejected i don't think jan nor
brian really cared that much though with
over a decade of experience within the
tech field they had already made plenty
of money so they decided to take it easy
and to go on a one-year vacation to
south america and play ultimate frisbee
when they came back jan would buy an
iphone in january of 2009 and this was
the beginning of whatsapp
as soon as jen got an iphone he says
that he knew that the app store was
going to be huge he started talking with
brian and another friend named alex
fishman about potential apps that they
could launch one month later on jen's
33rd birthday he would incorporate the
company whatsapp the name is of course a
reference to the popular saying what's
up despite incorporating the company jan
didn't really know what he wanted to
create he knew he wanted to do something
relating to social media hence the name
but initially he was actually leaning
towards status updates it wasn't until
august of 2009 that he incorporated a
messaging aspect into the app and this
is what really accelerated the adoption
of the app
at this point jan did most of the work
and owned the entirety of the company
in the meantime brian was still
unemployed and looking for potential
employment so jen offered to make brian
a co-founder if you could raise the
companies of money fortunately for brian
this was rather easy he hit up a couple
of friends from yahoo and was able to
raise a total of 250 000 for whatsapp
and with that brian and jan were able to
go all in on whatsapp from the very
beginning one of the duo's top
priorities was privacy jen says quote we
want to know as little about our users
as possible we're not advertisement
driven so we don't need personal
databases you could say that these were
some famous last words
anyway whatsapp quickly started to gain
popularity especially within developing
countries where whatsapp was the best
internet-based mobile messaging service
available hundreds of thousands of users
turned into millions of users and
millions of users turned into tens of
millions of users
despite the popularity of the app the
duo didn't really have a smart way to
monetize the app so they were burning
money left and right to keep operations
afloat fortunately in 2011 they would
successfully raise 8 million from
sequoia capital but both of them knew
that with how fast whatsapp was growing
it was just a matter of time until this
money would run out thankfully mark
would reach out just in time
whatsapp caught the attention of mark
zuckerberg very early on and mark would
quickly start building up a relationship
with jan and brian in 2012 mark called
jen and the two would get some coffee
and go on a hike over the next two years
the two would stay in contact and
eventually in february of 2014 mark
would invite jan over for dinner and
during dinner mark made jen an offer he
couldn't refuse
i'm gonna make him an offering
he offered to buy the money losing
company with little revenue for a
whopping 19 billion dollars whatsapp was
definitely not worth anywhere near 19
billion at the time but mark could see
the long-term potential of the company
meanwhile jen likely knew that whatsapp
could eventually go well past 19 billion
naturally but that would be a long and
tough journey filled with risk so taking
the buyout was a no-brainer soon after
jan would send the acquisition papers on
the door of his old welfare office and
with that jan and brian were officially
billionaires with the backing of
facebook jen and brian were able to test
and implement new features faster than
ever before
one of the first features they
implemented after the acquisition was
voice calls and by june of 2016 more
than 100 million voice calls were being
placed on whatsapp on a daily basis soon
after they launched video calls two-step
verification and whatsapp business aside
from introducing new features whatsapp
could relax a monetization effort thanks
to facebook so in january of 2016 they
would remove their annual one dollar fee
which made whatsapp more accessible than
ever before
despite all these advantages there were
also a few notable disadvantages namely
a reduction in user privacy during the
summer of 2016 whatsapp would begin
sharing user info with facebook for
targeted ads neither brian nor jan were
big fans of this decision and they would
both leave facebook soon after but not
before securing their full stock
compensations
ryan was the first to leave facebook in
september of 2017 and jan would leave
facebook seven months later in april of
2018. ironically both of them would
start trashing facebook as soon as they
left jan has expressed his grievances
about facebook to the media on several
occasions meanwhile brian straight up
advocates for people to delete facebook
clearly money hasn't bought their
loyalty but anyway jan has more or less
retired ever since he left facebook and
we don't really hear that much from him
the only time his name comes up in the
media nowadays is whenever he makes
another large donation one of his
largest donations was 556 million
dollars to the silicon valley community
foundation jan says that facebook barely
changed his life and that he still lives
in the same house hangs out with the
same friends and more or less does the
same things he just has a lot more money
in his bank account brian on the other
hand is more active than ever before
with the signal foundation one of the
first things brian did after leaving
facebook was founding a competing
messaging platform called signal signal
is a nonprofit messaging platform that
focuses on collecting as little data as
possible everything on the app is
encrypted and so far brian has funded it
with 100 million dollars of his own
money signal has actually become quite
popular growing an active user base of
40 million users as of the start of 2021
and given the virtuous goals of signal
and how much funding they have i can't
see why the app won't just become even
more popular within the coming years
eventually they may even be able to give
telegram and whatsapp a run for their
money which is the goal so brian may end
up being known for founding not one but
two game-changing messaging platforms
one for himself and one for the people
do you guys think signal can replace
whatsapp comment that down below
also drop a like if you're glad that
brian is standing up to facebook and of
course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one